Ach du Scheiße.
Oh Shit!
Milch ist Gift.
Ja.
*Musik*
Freunde der Sonne, hier ist Mai,
eure Chemikerin des Vertrauens.
Und ich würde sagen, es ist Zeit,
für ein bisschen Ruhe,
für Tee und ein paar
wissenschaftliche Fakten.
Lass uns schnell anfangen,
denn ich bin ein bisschen erkältet.
Oder wurde ich von Milch vergiftet?
Aaaaah!
Findet es heraus.
Ich habe mir 3 Fragen raus gesucht,
die ich wissenschaftlich
beantworten möchte.
Nämlich:
1. Was ist Milch überhaupt genau?.
2. Ist Milchgift? - Ja.
Und 3. Ist Unge ein PR-Genie?
Und ja, auch diese Frage werde ich
wissenschaftlich beantworten.
Nummer 1: was ist Milch eigentlich?
Muttermilch enthält alles,
was ein Baby so braucht:
Wasser, Kohlenhydrate bzw. Zucker,
Proteine, Mineralien, Vitamine,
Antikörper, Hormone.
Während Babys den Milchzucker,
also die Laktose,
noch problemlos abbauen können,
verlieren die meisten Menschen
diese Fähigkeit
sobald sie aufwachsen.
Der Großteil der Menschen
ist laktoseintolerant.
Nämlich ca. 65 %.
In Vietnam z.B. sind es 90 %,
die Laktose nicht vertragen.
Vietnamesen kann man also
ganz gut mit Milch vergiften.
Vor ca. 8000 Jahren begann sich
in einigen Bereichen der Welt
eine bestimmte Genmutation
durchzusetzen,
die es den Menschen erlaubte,
Milchzucker abzubauen,
so das heutzutage
ca. 35 % Milch trinken können,
ohne davon
Bauchschmerzen zu bekommen.
So, woher kommt die Milch?
Naja, dass die Milch
von der Kuh kommt, das weiß ja jeder.
Aber warum jetzt ausgerechnet
die Muttermilch von Kühen trinken,
ist nicht unbedingt
direkt nachvollziehbar.
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch jemand,
2011 sorgte eine Londoner Eisdiele
für einen Skandal,
weil sie eine Eissorte
mit Muttermilch herausbrachte.
Haaaa. Muttermilch
von einer fremden Frau? Abartig.
Aber dass wir uns morgens Muttermilch
eines fremden Tieres
auf unser Müsli schütten, daran
haben wir uns inzwischen gewöhnt.
Kuhmilch hat z.B.
auch einen ähnlichen Fettgehalt
wie Menschenmilch.
Aber der Hauptgrund ist, dass Kühe
so ertragreiche Milchgeber sind,
so das sich Kuhmilch etablierte
und heute so beliebt ist.
Deutschland konsumiert pro Jahr
rund 7,5 Mio. Tonnen
Frischmilcherzeugnisse.
Um dem nachzukommen werden oft
sog. "Turbokühe" eingesetzt.
Eine Zuchtrasse
namens Holstein-Friesian,
kurz auch HF-Kühe genannt.
Während im Jahre 1955 eine Kuh ca.
4000 l Milch pro Jahr produzierte,
liefert einer HF-Kuh
bis zu 15.000 l pro Jahr.
Und folgendes ist vielen
vielleicht auch nicht bewusst:
In Großbetrieben werden die Kühe
quasi dauerschwanger gehalten,
damit sie auch
ganzjährlich Milch produzieren.
Die Kühe werden nach der Entbindung
relativ schnell wieder
neu künstlich besamt,
damit sie eben jedes Jahr kalben.
Entsprechend leben solche Turbokühe
in der Regel nicht besonders lange.
Nach ein paar Jahren treten oft
"Berufskrankheiten" auf.
Die Kühe werden aussortiert
und landen dann beim Schlachter.
Zum Glück gibt es auch Ausnahmen.
Und es gibt Milchbauern,
die sich dem Trend entgegensetzen
und trotzdem Kunden finden,
die dazu bereit sind,
für den Liter Milch
mehr als nur'n paar Cent zu zahlen.
Aber die meiste Milch, die bei uns
auf'm Frühstückstisch landet,
kommt eben nicht von der grünen Alm,
so wie sie
in der Werbung gezeigt wird,
sondern von regelrecht
gezüchteten Milchmaschinen.
Okay, Frage Nummer 2:
Ist Milch Gift? - Aaaah!
Ich kann das nachvollziehen,
wenn man denkt,
dass Milch trinken
einfach nicht richtig sein kann.
Der Mensch ist nicht nur
das einzige Tier,
das als Erwachsener
noch weiterhin Muttermilch trinkt,
sondern er ist auch noch
das einzige Tier,
dass die Muttermilch
eines anderen Tieres trinkt.
Ein bisschen seltsam ist das schon.
Aber der Mensch macht viele Sachen,
die andere Tiere nicht machen.
Und nur weil etwas seltsam ist,
hat das noch keine
medizinische Aussagekraft.
Was hier zählt
sind wissenschaftliche Fakten.
Erstens: Kalzium und Knochen.
Kalzium ist wichtig
für unser Knochenwachstum.
Und Milch
ist eine gute Kalziumsquelle.
1 l Milch enthält
ca. 1200 mg Kalzium.
Und die empfohlene Tagesmenge
sind 1000 mg.
Es besteht ein wissenschaftlicher
Konsens darüber,
dass Milch für Kinder und Jugendliche
in der Wachstums-
und Knochenaufbauphase
einen gesundheitlichen Vorteil hat.
Uneinig sind sich
Wissenschaftler allerdings,
wenn es um
Osteoporose geht.
Osteoporose
ist eine altersbedingte Krankheit,
bei der Knochen brüchig werden.
Man hört immer wieder,
dass Milch Osteoporose fördert,
weil in Ländern,
in denen viel Milch getrunken wird,
häufiger Osteoporose auftritt.
Das ist aber nur eine Korrelation
und keine Kausalität.
Ein Zusammenhang aber keine Ursache.
Sehr wichtiger Unterschied.
Sagen wir in Deutschland
leiden mehr Menschen an Osteoporose
als in Vietnam.
Außerdem wird in Deutschland vielmehr
Milch getrunken als in Vietnam.
Das kann theoretisch bedeuten,
dass Milch Osteoporose verursacht,
muss es aber nicht.
Es kann auch genauso gut Zufall sein.
Denn zwischen Deutschland und Vietnam
gibt es viele Unterschiede.
Nicht nur den Milchkonsum.
Genauso ist die Gesundheit
von Knochen
von vielen
verschiedenen Faktoren abhängig.
Vor allem von genetischen Faktoren.
Aber auch von Körpergewicht,
von Rauchen, von Hormonen
wie Östrogenen...
Also, es gibt kein Grund zur Sorge,
dass Milch
schlecht für unsere Knochen ist.
Aber es gibt auch genauso wenig
wissenschaftliche Hinweise dafür,
dass Milch gut für unsere Knochen
ist, wenn wir bereits Erwachsen sind.
Zweitens: Milch und Krebs.
Milch enthält, zu geringem Teil,
sogenannte Wachstumsfaktoren.
Wachstumsfaktoren nennt man Proteine,
die bei biologischen
Prozessen beteiligt sind,
die mit Wachstum zu tun haben.
Das kann einmal
das normale Wachstum sein.
Zum Beispiel: In Ländern,
wo viel Milch konsumiert wird,
sind die Menschen auch größer.
Wir können weder sagen, ob die Milch
wirklich eine Ursache dafür ist,
und noch weniger können wir sagen,
ob es die Wachstumsfaktoren
in der Milch sind,
oder irgendwelche anderen
Bestandteile. Z.B. das Kalzium.
Wachstumsfaktoren können aber auch
Zellwachstum, Zellteilung fördern.
Und damit im schlimmsten Fall
auch das Wachstum von Krebs.
Z.B. gibt es einige Studien,
die Korrelationen zwischen
Prostatakrebs und Milchkonsum sehen.
Korrelationen sind, wie gesagt,
nur bedingt aussagekräftig.
Aber bei Krebsverdacht sollte man
mögliche Risikofaktoren
durchaus ernst nehmen.
Was aber wiederum gegen den Einfluss
von Wachstumsfaktoren spricht,
ist die Tatsache,
dass kein Zusammenhang
mit irgend einer anderen Krebsart
bisher gefunden wurde.
Im Gegenteil:
Im Fall von Darmkrebs hat man sogar
eine positive Korrelation gefunden.
Also, Milchkonsum zusammenhängend
mit verringertem Krebsrisiko.
Drittens: Diabetes und
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen.
Auch hier gibt es
keinen wissenschaftlich
fundierten Grund zur Sorge.
Allerdings sollte man sich
über ein paar andere Zusammenhänge
bewusst werden.
Kritisch sind z.B. fettreduzierte,
fettarme Milchprodukte.
Wer z.B. gern fettarmen Joghurt isst,
muss sich darüber im Klaren sein,
dass die Fettreduzierung oft mit
mehr Zuckerzusatz kompensiert wird.
Denn sonst würde das ja
auch nicht schmecken.
Viertens: Milch und Akne. - Aaaah!
Ja, Milch kann bei Jugendlichen
die Talgproduktion erhöhen,
die ja sowieso schon erhöht ist, was
zu Pickeln und zu Akne führen kann.
Auch hier sind bisher nur
Zusammenhänge, also Korrelationen,
und keine direkten Kausalitäten
nachgewiesen.
Aber man kann ja mal durch
Milchverzicht einen Selbsttest machen
und schauen, was es einem bringt.
Denn eins ist klar,
eine gesunde Ernährung ist
sicherlich auch möglich ohne Milch.
Kalzium, Protein und auch
Vitaminquellen gibt es viele andere.
Nur als Gift würde ich Milch
jetzt nicht bezeichnen.
Wobei natürlich auch
die Dosis das Gift macht.
Ihr wisst schon, alles
ist giftig ab 'ner gewissen Dosis.
Ist Milch allerdings
ein Gift für den Planeten?
Da fällt mir
direkt das Teeetikett ab.
Dazu muss ich mal
ein Extra-Video machen
oder am besten direkt
eine ganze Reihe.
Ich selbst bin keine Veganerin,
auch keine Vegetarierin, leider.
Vielleicht schaffe ich
das irgendwann mal.
Ich unterstütze alle
Vegetrarier und alle Veganer.
Und in dieser Hinsicht unterstütze
ich damit auch Unge,
weil ich weiß, das alles andere
einfach nicht nachhaltig ist.
Aber bevor ich jetzt hier
ein Fass aufmache,
das ich an dieser Stelle
gar nicht angemessen angehen kann,
kommen wir doch lieber zur 3. Frage.
Nämlich: Ist Unge ein PR-Genie?
Unges "Milch ist Gift"-Video
war sicherlich höchst effektiv darin,
eine Diskussion auszulösen.
Aber nicht die beste Methode, um eine
konstruktive Diskussion zu schaffen.
Es gibt ein gut untersuchtes
psychologisches Phänomen
namens Confirmation Bias.
Jeder leidet darunter,
der einige mehr, der andere weniger.
Aber niemand ist wirklich frei davon.
Confirmation Bias heißt letztendlich,
dass ich an meiner eigenen Meinung
festhalte, egal was kommt.
Außerdem ist
erschreckend gut untersucht:
Wenn wir uns einmal
einen Eindruck gebildet haben,
dann lassen wir den nicht los.
Auch wenn wir wissen,
dass dieser Eindruck
oder diese Meinung falsch ist.
Ich hab dazu auch schon ein, zwei
Videos gemacht. Verlink ich euch.
Jedenfalls war es deswegen ziemlich
ungeschickt, Ungeschickt,
dass Unge im Video sowas sagt wie:
Wenn ihr mindestens zweimal täglich
Milch und Milchprodukte esst,
dann macht ihr euch krank.
Ihr könnt euch das vorstellen,
wie 'ne riesen Verschwörungstheorie.
Wir werden systematisch krank gemacht
mit den Lebensmitteln.
Carla möchte nicht mehr,
dass die Bevölkerung krank wird,
Carla möchte in Zukunft
gesunde Menschen in ihrem Land haben.
Jetzt hat er im 2. Video eingeräumt,
dass er bewusst auch
provozieren wollte,
und dass Milch
für den Einzelnen
vielleicht doch nicht
ganz so kritisch ist.
Dass Veganismus aber trotzdem
der richtige Weg ist.
Es gibt unzählige weitere Studien
über den gesundheitlichen Aspekt
von Milch.
Allerdings kommt man
im Body of Evidence zum Ergebnis,
dass zum jetzigen Standpunkt
mehr Studien für einen Milchkonsum,
vor allem im Kindesalter,
sprechen, als dagegen.
Wenn jetzt wirklich
gar nicht klar bewiesen ist,
dass Milch ungesund ist,
bzw. krank macht,
warum habe ich dann, die zugegeben,
provokante Aussage getroffen,
dass Milch Gift sei?
Es ist nicht eindeutig belegt,
dass Milch ganzheitlich schädlich
für den einzelnen Menschen ist.
Aber Milch ist Gift für die Tiere,
die davon betroffen sind
und ausgebeutet werden.
Und Milch ist Gift
für unseren Planeten,
da der CO2-Ausstoß
und die Grundwasserverseuchung
durch die Viehhaltung
um ein Vielfaches höher ist,
als die von Autos und Flugzeugen.
Das Problem ist nur, jeder, der
sich nach dem 1. Video gedacht hat,
"Häh, was für'n verschwörungs-
theoretischer Bullshit!",
wird Unges guten Argumenten im
2. Video kein Glauben mehr schenken.
Den Eindruck, den er
im 1. Video vermittelt hat,
wird er jetzt im Nachhinein
kaum mehr revidieren können.
Und damit hat er möglicherweise vor
allem diejenigen Menschen verloren,
die er am ehesten erreichen wollte,
nämlich die Vegankritiker.
Deswegen finde ich
es 'nen bisschen schade,
dass die durchaus guten Argumente,
die Unge jetzt in seinem
2. Video angesprochen hat,
in dem ganzen Halligalli
so'n bisschen untergehen.
Und dass der große Sturm,
den Unge ja nach eigener Aussage
bewusst provoziert hat,
so'n bisschen um die falschen
Argumente heraufbeschwört wurde.
Aber ihr seid Freunde der Sonne
und damit Freunde
des sachlichen Austauschs.
Deswegen schreibt mir doch
in die Kommentare,
was ihr zum Milch-Gate denkt.
Und schreibt auch gerne eure Fragen
und Gedanken zum Thema Veganismus.
Denn ich würde tatsächlich gerne mal
einen längeren Beitrag
dazu produzieren und eure Fragen
auch gerne mit einbeziehen.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
Freunde der Sonne, bleibt sicher.
Aaaah!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
(schnaubt)
(hustet)
(schnieft, stöhnt)
(schnaubt)
Ha Shit.